yeah welcome to this video 15 minute
game and let you form and got the car
come yeah I'm obviously many systems
available that white can play almost
like them advance or the pan off never
been such a huge fan of Knight c3 or 92
but it's a matter of taste of course let
some go for the pan off very often
leading to isolated Queen porn
structures
yeah 96 or some the probably sharpest
move into position g6 it's also fine
here the main choices between Knight f3
and Bishop to g5 yeah I don't really
know the fear that one I always have
slight fear of the opponents sitting
there with the book and looking up the
lines simply because it's 15 minutes yes
say I'm not accusing it this person
specifically but it's just if you play
something that you don't know too well
and 15 minutes as you could easily look
it up in a book if you have one way to
the law of use the database or something
okay but he's thinking now this is
somewhat reassuring
can I have three years the alternative
which is usually answered by Bishop g4
all the interesting move three six to
six or seven five would recommend them
myself to play interesting a Bishop g5
is maybe somewhat sharper then I have
three the idea
is simple to take f65 someone black
needs to react in some way yeah the
normal way to go is actually detects a
form night before I'm not sure about
this is this is good yeah but what
what's my reply I am sometimes you can
answer night if I with C takes d5 C
takes d5 Knight takes d5 and H for the
night is so trapped it doesn't have a
square I can go not you for probably
back Knight takes d4 Queen d5 and black
is better so I need to move the bishop
or take a form and moving the bishop
looks and somewhat somewhat slow maybe
it is is okay
Bishop to h4 simpler but maybe he can
really go Queen a5 some some stuff like
that okay what's your turn if I can take
and play d5 so some text the night now
come on I must I must move at some point
and now d5 winning a tempo on this on
this night
yeah just centralizing and the question
is what now more than one interesting
way to get to continue I can play very
directly queen deform just a techy five
and deform and maybe this is a simple
and good solution just a double attack
hmm come on don't see a refutation at
the moment and I'm already I'm bit
behind in time so I'd like to catch up a
bit the clock it just seems like a
double attack you know maybe this is the
refutation of 94
this is d5 924 first of all don't really
see what like black has now the other
night is also just the Tecton town if
you he retreated it's just just a pawn
96 context you form it's even now tricky
for black to to get get developed f6 is
a possibility but I have Bishop f4 as a
reply or simply Queenie form F K's g5
does came so protecting this way
okay so just context before or is there
something something better it looks it
looks fine to me
maybe maybe e6 Assam is six and Bishop
before yeah this this could be a good
player annoying
yeah Bishop f4 immediately is answered
by an ID check and the the bishop is
hanging on on a farm I don't don't want
that okay come on let's take this now he
six was the move that irritated me okay
really he's six and Bishop two to be
formed so I'm on Bishop f4 he's going
Bishop to g7 and Knight f3 I can take
with check this is a little shame what
else I could I could go even f4 and
where does this this night go or or an
ad or something with with d6 also also
rather problematic like rookie one
Bishop g7 and D and D 6 and also also
quite tricky for black yeah bottom
everything's good here it's just just a
fine position
okay let's just go from completing
development a Bishop f5 force I was an
additional idea but it's not too much of
a problem oh yeah we should be to was
probably not the best move
it's sloppy Knight takes e4 I can play
Queen c3 and his son depend on the C
philanthropy saying 23 once what's the
big big point seems like a double attack
can play em f6 but Bishop c4 is still
not threatening the the bishop because
of the pin yeah now I have before right
maybe
let's and that's thing for just a moment
Queen 85 I can take just see for right
it so it's a it's a piece pushups you
form simply a piece no no he's
continuing its um just piece down for
not much okay so a check here I guess
getting the King on on on th cannot be
not be too bad let's just complete
development iam
the APIs should be - how how to finish
this this quickly
maybe rook to d1 41 he takes on e
talking into Group C 3 I've got d6 and
then it's it's opening up really quickly
threatening of D take c7 with complete
destruction okay it's on and I get a new
queen alright shag made
yeah and mate yeah probably the slightly
formal that's just not working in the
opening I mean let's check this briefly
all the computer actually isn't too
thrilled
I now know it it switches to some
advantage for what we are 95 24 and and
now computer gives f6 with still rather
decent play I'm not sure it looks it
looks a bit a bit strange to meet this
line but I'm not an expert
yeah thanks for watching